so corporate wokeness has now gone to
extraordinary lengths uh
they're now apparently at ikea just
making ugly crap they're just making
ugly crap and if they slap like a
bisexual slogan on it
then we are supposed to apparently take
seriously their commitment to wokeness
now it just seems to me at this point we
are living in a world of
corporate indulgences it's like the old
school 12th century catholic indulgences
where you go out
and you shut up the neighbor's wife and
then you go to church you're like well
if you give a thousand
crowns then everything is good you're
like okay done
right so i i feel like that is is what
we have now with corporate
america and and foreign corporations as
well this idea like if
you pay off the woke then they will just
ignore the fact that you're doing
business with like slave labor in china
right it's what nike does
all the time okay so ikea has decided to
market
furniture that not a single human will
ever buy
like not a single human will ever buy
this
okay so here is um an ad for ikea
this is just hideous it's just hideous
there are many different pride flags oh
boy
each flag represents a different
identity which defeats the purpose of a
flag
we created ikea love seats inspired by
them oh my gosh
so okay um i'm gonna need to go back and
pause on some of these
because these are the ugliest couches
and like forget about the politics of it
these are the ugliest couches i have
ever seen in my entire life
like not to be stereotypical
but i thought that style was at some
point
required of ikea
i mean i don't even think that's it
that's just like it's a business
shouldn't they have like some
okay inspired by the non-binary flag
apparently
the nice thing about this particular
gray couch is that you can carry it
using the straps randomly attached to it
that
presumably fit under your butt while you
sit
uh that sounds pretty terrible this
looks like an awful couch this isn't
even the other this isn't close to the
ugliest one by the way let's go to the
next one
so we can we can see these one by one
because they are
masterpieces of hideousness inspired by
the transgender flag
this is a love seat with clouds attached
i know you're supposed to put your leg
and the transgender flag wrapping its
way
in like weird rainbow formation
across the back of the couch like this
this just looks hideously uncomfortable
this is actually one of the least
ugly ones hey wait inspired by the
progress
pride flag it's a couch covered in
flowers
i don't know where you're supposed to
sit on this remember a couch is a place
for your ass
i don't know where you are supposed to
sit on this couch it it is it is
though a garden took over your couch
okay this one is clearly the ugliest
it's it's
almost dystopian in its ugliness it's
it's just
it's a fever dream yeah it's like
somebody
read the dr seuss book hunches and
bunches and then proceeded to take a
heavy dose of lsd
and come up with a design for this couch
it is inspired by the bisexual flag
and it says on the pillows when you
change or to anne
nobody believes you okay so now it's
just
a complaint couch also the couch is like
covered in hands for those who can't
actually see it
it's it's actually covered in hand
prints and there are two
human arms coming out of the couch
and and two other hands coming out of
the couch it looks like something from
the shining
like it you're going to be strangled by
to death by your own bisexual couch
who is going to buy this and why
and how inspired by the pansexual flag
apparently
uh they they found a pansexual colorful
cow and just skinned it and put it
directly on this particular loveseat
and no one's gonna buy any of this crap
no one's gonna buy any of it
the lesbian flag couch is uh is the
least
ugly and that's that's really saying a
lot it's it's like
still ugly but i don't know what it has
to do with lesbianism per se
it's just the colors of the lesbian flag
um and um
the gender fluid flag looks just like
somebody spilled ink
all over it it just looks like it's it's
like purple and pink and white but then
there are these big black blotches all
over the couch
as though an amoeba had been had
been blown up to life-size like giant
and then
then there's the transgender flag which
uh is just a bunch of google doodles
so well done ikea i'm sure they will
sell thousands of these things
or alternatively they are just pandering
to the lgbt woke crowd
so that you will shop at ikea and never
buy one of these couches but feel super
good about yourself
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang